so after I graduated from Hillsdale a
long time ago I went out well to this
state to Clermont to study for my PhD in
political science and that's where I met
our next speaker and his lovely wife
penny at the time he was president of
the Claremont Institute a position he
held for fifteen years before he came to
Hillsdale he didn't offer any formal
classes back then but he still did a lot
of teaching informally and I learned a
lot from him from his speeches and in
conversation as I still do today in
addition to learning from him I quickly
learned something about him I learned he
knew a lot a lot more than I did and
also that he's a good teacher and like
all good teachers his goal was helping
us to find the truth about whatever it
is we were talking about her studying as
a practical matter this meant that if
you claim to know something in his
presence it made you something of a ripe
target well if you if you come to campus
come to Hillsdale and we hope that you
will you can sit in on one of his
classes or have lunch with him and some
students in the student in the student
dining hall and what you'll see is he
hasn't changed Tibet it's been my
privilege to work with him at my alma
mater for now almost 19 years his topic
today is American principals and public
policy would you please welcome back to
the podium the 12th president of
Hillsdale College Larry P R
[Applause]
I'm very lucky with the people in the
people that with whom I get to work in
Tim Kaspar and Matt Bell who both
introduced me today we have the long and
the short of the matter thank you all
for coming
do you like Andrew Roberts he's a is he
still here yeah is he over there
I are you signing books out there yeah I
go by a book he he I was in terror I've
known him for a very long time and I was
in terror last night that he would
debunk one of the best Churchill jokes
and he and Richard langworth are
complicit in debunking the Churchill
joke that Churchill walked into the
public the men's room at the House of
Commons and Clement Attlee was there and
when Stan Churchill went down to the
other end of this facility and Clement
Attlee said are you feeling standoffish
Winston comedy Atlee was the first
majority socialist prime minister in
history and actually a friend of Winston
Churchill's literally fought like cats
and dogs about domestic policy and
Churchill replied Clement every time you
see something big you try to nationalize
it
[Applause]
now there was a grievous time that arose
where this was denied that this was the
truth and we first of all obviously it
ought to be the truth but using my
powers the president of Hillsdale
College and my relationship with Richard
langworth I said we got to look this up
better and you know sure enough we found
a sir a source to confirm it and so
there's no more of that all these really
great stories about what's in Churchill
whether they're true or not we're
accepting them all okay I'm going to
talk about principle and policy a little
bit this morning and try to distinguish
them they're related and they're
different and the reason I think this is
good to do is probably the reason Doug
Jeffery thought of this conference and
that is everything is in flux right now
it may be a realignment do you sense
that and you know it might go badly or
well depending you know but in
realignment those are very rare the the
abiding majority party in the United
States changed in 1800
after the Revolution when Jefferson
destroyed the Federalist Party and it
changed in the 1860s when the Republican
Party was born and became the majority
party until the New Deal and it has been
that more or less ever since since the
New Deal and that's let's invent it a
different form of government the
government is much larger than it used
to be but it also operates very
differently
it doesn't make its laws in the same way
as it used to
it doesn't enforce the laws the same way
used to and maybe that's changing I
actually think it's like a house divided
as Lincoln said that it's got to be one
thing or the other and right now it's
some of both and it's going to be
resolved somehow and for good or ill
we'll see but as this starts to happen
we get confused because it's hard to
tell at any moment what's going on
sometimes there are huge changes of
policy that don't amount to a change in
principle I'll give you an example in
the Civil War parts of the Union made
war on other parts and the result of it
was that the federal government got the
power to forbid slavery in the States
it lacked that power before now is that
a change in principle Lincoln's claim
was no it wasn't because why because the
founders themselves were hostile to
slavery and they didn't have the means
to stop it and so they stopped it as far
as they could and that it took a war
finally to stop it and he regretted that
but the war resolved a contradiction
that was only practical in its nature
because at the founding there was an
agreement it had to go I think it was
abolished in more than 60% of the Union
pretty soon but between that founding
and the Civil War a new idea had grown
up I'm going to tell you about another
one in contemporary times and the new
idea was that slavery was a good thing
because these people are inferior we now
know that human societies and human
beings evolved and the ones so that
means by the way not all men are created
equal that means depending on how you've
grown and how you've evolved and where
you've got to and John Calhoun wrote
that these black people are inferior and
it would be an abomination to live with
them as equal citizens and as I say that
idea was not present in the American
Revolution but you know they all said
this is a troubling thing and even from
South Carolina the Charles Pinckney
there were a lot of Pinkney's and one of
them was not as good as his brother
Charles but
he was into constitutional convention
and he did and others did operate to
keep at the declaration of independence
dimension of slavery out of it but not
because they ever claimed that it was a
good thing it was that it was too much
to try to deal with in the middle of a
revolution so there was a change in
principle under way and that's what led
to the Civil War as it were itself
restored according to Lincoln the
situation that had prevailed now I'll
just distinguish principle principle and
policy quickly it principle is it's a
Latin comes from a Latin word and it
means first the first thing it means is
first it's like primary the Greek
equivalent is RK we get an architect
from that and it means the first thing
what is the first thing in Primus means
in the first place its cognate with
Principia and and so the first thing
just means just beginning you know first
step you take but it comes to meaning a
lot more than that and it has to mean a
lot more than that because if a thing is
the thing excuse me this is a little
philosophy here but it's not much if a
thing is a thing then it's a moment of
its founding is when it becomes that
thing so the first thing principle also
means the way we most commonly think of
the word which is the ruling idea the
essence the definition of a thing the
controlling thing about it that's our K
is like that in Greek that's you know in
in the beginning was the word in the
word for beginning is our K but it means
something more than just where it
started it means when it became what it
was a year x' ago I haven't done it for
some years but I'd like briefly today I
looked up the mission statements of the
Ivy League colleges if I could find them
and I went to their websites this is not
an exactly academic paper that I was
writing I was looking up so I could say
bad stuff about him if they had if they
had abandoned their missions and you
know I found only one that featured on
its website prominently its founding and
that's University of Pennsylvania which
was founded by Ben Franklin its first
president and it makes quite a lot of
that how great he was and all that and
then it says that we carry on today as
he did in an atmosphere of global and
multicultural studies and so I went you
know there's a really great paper that
Ben Franklin wrote about the founding to
in aid of as a principal of the founding
of the University of Pennsylvania and it
goes on and on about studying all over
the world in ancient world included in
order to find the best and then he goes
on to say what the best is which is free
faithful limited government right that
means he excludes very much of human
experience but he wants to know all of
human experience not multiculturalism
but discovering what culture really is
now the point is the University of
Pennsylvania I haven't looked lately but
at least when I did that a few years ago
they were making a lot of that principle
but the question is are they the same
thing anymore because you see if you
change the principle you make a new and
different beginning it's not the same
thing anymore if John C Calhoun had got
his way it would have been a different
country because it wouldn't be the
principle anymore all men are created
equal it would be the principle those
who evolved the same condition are equal
and since evolution is an ongoing
process then the security for the rights
of man is a matter of daily observance
to see how far you've got and if you
fall behind
then laws would be justified
keep you in that spot forever change
that principle you change the place and
that's what Abraham Lincoln said and you
know one of the reasons it worked one of
the reasons he won because it was very
implausible that he would you learn if
you read the lincoln-douglas debates
that people north and south were very
divided about slavery most people didn't
like it especially in the north but it
maybe even in the South too but you know
people had this other thing going on
which was they didn't really like to
have a lot of black people around the
rule in in Illinois at the time was that
they may not come in there's no slavery
here and also there are no black people
here and Douglass taunts Lincoln with
that
and remember in in this is happening in
1860 in the American hey revolution
happened between 1763 and 1800s a so
this is two generations later two
generations in politics is a long time
it means it's just like in the college
business to get rid of a bad thing it
takes five years because they've all got
to graduate it's actually true you know
we have managed to reform a couple of
fraternities and it took five years and
you know and they weren't terrible but
they just had the wrong idea about their
fraternity and then you know then they
handed on down to the next and the next
and the next and we finally decided we
needed a disruption here to use the word
to mr. Speicher just used and we got it
and you know they're all being good
right now I'll check when I get back
but what what and so Lincoln is
targeting Douglas Douglas does in the
lincoln-douglas debates is he's trying
to prove that if you get what Lincoln
recommends you're gonna get
intermarriage between blacks and whites
and nobody wants that
and of course nobody ever in a free
country in a in a peaceful country as we
are I mean we're very warlike for a
peaceful country but we don't prefer the
war in a free country like that nobody
wants to go fight a big war and so
Douglas is you know it's remarkable what
he says he says that Lincoln you know
I'll have you know he said that this
very week in this very town Lincoln's
friend Fred Douglas you know the famous
black man who spoke at Hillsdale College
and all that we're very proud about that
has ridden through this town in a
carriage driven by a white man you want
that kind of thing vote for Lincoln and
Lincoln has to answer that you know and
it come to find out he was a genius he
could and he answered it so effectively
that Douglass his health was broken at
the end you know he decayed because
Lincoln said you you may be right that
the black woman is your inferior does
that mean you get to owner why don't you
let her alone why don't you give her the
same rights you claim for yourself and
see the magic of that right that
produced the energy that won the worst
war in our history and it was very hard
right Lincoln said of slavery forget
these fancy theories he said it's really
just a product of the old serpent and
man you work I'll eat
a question of principle was at stake
after we marshaled the whole society and
passed the amendments that abolished
slavery and guaranteed voting rights we
went back to limited government you see
a change of principle was threatened and
repelled and then the policies that had
gone with the old principles were
restored
now policy that comes from the word it's
caught light it's the same as the word
police and the word police is cognate
with the with the Greek word polis the
city policy is what city does and that
can mean a lot of things large and small
it's not a it's a broader term than the
term principal which means first thing
an essential thing right and so your
policies can be defining of something
urgent and indicative about you or not
and and and big things cannot make a lot
of difference like you know the British
my wife and Andrew they cannot figure
out which side of the road to drive on
it's a terrible disability and and you
know one time I I Drive over there but
one time after we were married but still
living over there I came home for a
couple of weeks and I got back in town
at night and my wife I inherited from
her the worst car in the world and
Austin many back when they were still
made in Britain and it led us down on
every important occasion including going
away for our honeymoon and but I you
know I got I got home and I we needed
something and I got in the car to go and
I reminded myself and I pulled out and
down the street comes a pair of
headlights look right at me and of
course I panicked and managed to pull
off the road and then the guy goes by
and who was it it was some confused
American he was on the wrong side of the
road and and see that you know that
doesn't make a difference you know the
House of Commons back when it was really
great
I don't know Andrews isn't going to be
restored it's really different from the
Congress of the United States but in
another way the same thing we elect them
they argue we get to hear the argument
and then they vote and do something just
like here the House of Commons is not
sovereign in the way it used to be
because most of the laws in Britain too
are made outside the Parliament but when
they were made that it's the same idea
common in principle although it looks
different in policy so if you can get
those things distinguished in your mind
remember I mentioned something and that
is the American government looks
physically looks visibly looks different
than it used to look and if you go to
Washington DC I noticed this years ago
and it's one of my favorite observations
and I think it's true it's roughly true
that if something is operating in an
the building in Washington DC it is
unconstitutional and and if you look
here's where I saw this for the first
time I was on the National Mall and I
had my back to the Lincoln monument and
I was closer to the Capitol than the
Capitol is the grandest public building
in America and the one public building
in America that rivals the greatest
public buildings in Europe discusses
scale the White House is very beautiful
but it's not very big so I was looking
at that grand thing and I turned and I
was going to walk toward Lincoln which
is one of my favorite things to do and
there in my line of sight was the United
States Department of Education and
that's got to be you know just pug ugly
that thing indeed they're doing an
Eisenhower memorial with the purpose to
cover it up alas the Eisenhower Memorial
is also ugly so so I looked at that and
I looked at that and I looked at that
and I said wow that building is
constructed so that a lot of
functionaries or bureaucrats can work in
it and it looks like one of those things
one of those desks with roll-top and the
little cubby holes a bureau it is built
for a bureaucracy and then look back at
the Capitol and look again and look
again and I said you know there actually
is no place in the Capitol a huge
building for people who do that kind of
work to be it was not imagined and you
know Washington is a DC is a very
deliberately planned place you know it's
not like like London is one of the great
monumental cities in the world and you
know there's a roughly mile on a side
square where some of the greatest things
that have happened in history are
commemorated and they were built at the
time when those things happen and they
happened over a long period
time it's amazing it came out so grand
as it is especially in that part of
London but you know if you go down if
you if you start at Parliament Square
and you walk down Whitehall and you 10
Downing streets on the left they don't
let you go down there anymore and and
and you know you go past the Horse
Guards and da-da-da-da-da and you get to
Trafalgar Square and what's that about
well it's obvious what that's about
because you see those big lions around
that statue and they are made of Milton
down French cannon you know Andrews a
joke about the French last night the
word surrender that's British stuff
right there they really like that you
know in Nelson's way up at the top you
can't see him very well
but he's looking at France in case they
decided to come back
you see that's it's like that Washington
was like like the American government
it's different it was planned and it and
and then something new came and now it
encroaches the new encroaches on the
mall everywhere you see and I'm old
enough to have been going there when
that stuff wasn't there and I really
regret the change because the simplicity
of it and the grandeur of it and the
harmony of it was what they were after
was law fault and Thomas Jefferson and
George Washington planning the city they
did use a French architect
now I just want to mention one more
thing and then we'll Q&A if you want to
in this flux that's going on a big issue
is Donald Trump has been critical of
NATO and NATO is itself the product of a
revolution and a happy revolution and so
of course especially on the right people
accuse him of a betrayal of something
fundamental to American foreign policy
and I don't know whether he's guilty of
that or not for sure because he reveals
himself as he goes and you know I like
him I you know I confess it but but you
know also I watch and so I think I can
tell you how to think about that because
you know first of all you got to
understand the drama of the revolution
that produced all of that I mean NATO
and the Marshall Plan and all that and
that came after the American
intervention in two world wars those
were things we did both of those things
without an overall plan for what we were
how we were going to conduct ourselves
in the future it's just that here was an
emergency we were being attacked let's
go over there and cream those guys which
is what we did and you know with our
help with from the British for example
so after the Second World War some very
dramatic things happen and happened fast
Harry Truman you know who was nobody he
met Churchill for a few days at Potsdam
and then Churchill went home to count
the votes and got hammered and so only
clement attlee came back he'd been there
from the beginning and that means they
didn't talk for a while and the antrum
instance last night after that
devastating loss and remember Churchill
is awesome right and he's won that war
and he's beloved everywhere he goes and
then he gets hammered and he goes with
his daughter and he paints a bunch of
paintings at Lake Como and he nurses his
wounds it's the only time I ever know of
it and Andrew said last night it lasted
about two weeks he was really down you
know but he he said he said he wrote to
his wife I don't want to read the papers
and I don't want to see any strangers
we're doing all this right now the last
volume of the Churchill document volumes
is just about done we're gonna have a
big party in June and in London and
Andrew is gonna be speaking all come
anyway it we're doing these things and
they're exciting to read right because
after he's gone to Lake Como and licked
his wounds and by now it's the end of
July and he gets back and then the last
week of October he gets a letter and
remember he's just a opposition he's the
leader of the opposition but he's just
an opposition member of parliament it's
just that he's become the greatest man
in the world and after he became that I
don't know if Andrew agrees us but I
noticed that everybody friends and enemy
they remain friend or enemy as they had
been but now they were the friend or
enemy of the greatest man in the world
and and that's how they all acted right
and there's it's funny to watch you know
because before they would dismiss him
you know bad judgment too changeable
can't trust him right now oh yeah
Winston Churchill so he gets this letter
and the letter is from the president of
Westminster College and you know I and I
will tell you it's an honest truth I
cannot remember the name of the
president who wrote to him and the
reason is it isn't important if I ever
got to do something like that you
wouldn't remember my name either because
the PostScript is what's important Harry
Truman wrote PS something like this is a
college in my home district please come
I will introduce you
that's interesting and he doesn't know
Truman very well well he goes and see
it's it is a piece of genius political
cleverness
because if Churchill had been the Prime
Minister of Great Britain at that moment
this invitation probably wouldn't work
because that would commit Britain and
America to something whereas Churchill
is able to stand at the front of the
room and you know it's the sinews of
peace speech he calls it it's one of his
greatest speeches and mezame complete
account of the foreign policy that won
the Cold War
it's amazingly prophetic right and
brilliant but he says at the beginning
he says you know I've realized all my
ambitions there's nothing more to which
I could aspire now I'm just you know
private fella there is nothing here but
what do you see you mean right except I
got a photograph I went and researched
and found I got a photograph of him
beginning that speech and what you see
was Winston Churchill right here and
Harry Truman right there
having just introduced him and then he
makes the declarations that open the
Cold War now
Truman denied having read the speech and
didn't state in the opinion about it
Churchill did the day before had said
cabled to the cabinet Clement Attlee
cabinet back in in Washington back in
London that they'd gone over the speech
and Truman thought it was strong and
approved it but Truman didn't have to
say that and you know the world just got
into an uproar all the reliables right I
can tell you the judgment of the New
York Times was just about back then as
good as it is now and you know this is
amazing consistency in those people and
and and Stalin himself erupts and then
gives interviews erupting and so
what follows first of all what preceded
a few days was that the Turkish
ambassador in Washington had died and so
Truman sent his body back in a naval
flotilla of great strength and then soon
you get the Marshall Plan and you get
NATO and you get the European Union and
that is a change in American foreign
policy of fundamental importance and
there's no legacy of that previous in
America there's just hints of it here
and there like Teddy Roosevelt's white
fleet going around the world and him
arbitrating disputes there's some things
like that but you know the real
principle is the Monroe Doctrine and
entangling alliances and so we departed
from that and we in Truman in America
not so much as Churchill they had their
empire for a long time
he's accused of a betrayal of principle
of a change in principle and yet sure
enough that thing has been the polity
you know we're used to not just thinking
ours selves the greatest country in the
world we thought that when we wrote the
Declaration independence and they were
hardly any of us right we've always been
a little full of ourselves like I Andrew
says that that's the genius of the
British people and I reply not alone see
and so so now something new we're used
to being involved all over the place
and so are we gonna discard that now
well here's what I think about that I
think I know what the criteria are to
think about it first of all if you read
this fulton speech is March the fifth
1946 you can find it on the internet
easy you should read it through it's
quiet of production also it'll make you
sad a little bit because who talks like
that today who can write like that
you know it's it's a different sort of
thing than which one encounters and and
you know I think the same thing when I
read Abraham Lincoln but then the scale
of what Churchill wrote it's just
awesome you know
Lincoln was in politics for nine years
he gave maybe 20 maybe 15 major speeches
Churchill just fills up books you know
with all that stuff and writes his own
books too I don't I can't account for it
I don't think it can be accounted for so
you read that speech and here's what you
find first of all it's a it it's a
movement the speech there's a coherence
to it it starts out with a bunch of
sweeping generalities first the first
one is America you're the man and you've
got responsibility primacy and power
comes responsibility
and he says then we have to have to get
rid of the tumor writers and their war
and tyranny and our aim should be to
protect every home the said the health
and the comfort and safety the health
and welfare of every home in every land
around the world that's a big deal isn't
it you know so somebody that that and
nobody's ever quite said that much in
American politics that I know but then
when you read this page you find out
that and then how you start stop war the
United Nations which should have courts
and constables and arms this is that
everybody think that's a good idea today
so then he begins to qualify and Mark
you what's he trying to do in 1952 when
Churchill has resumed the Premiership he
gets a report that since the American
and British military buildup is
recommenced after the second world war
over the last three year period the
Soviets had built twice as many
airplanes as britain in the united
states combined and they have an
overwhelming majority and tanks and
numbers of soldiers and readiness to
fight beyond anything if they want to go
to the atlantic ocean they can go and
what stops them so first of all remember
churchill is trying to build a coalition
worldwide to stop those guys and also
what they represent and so he thinks
grandly and of course he's got used to
big numbers
you know his commitment to the empire is
not just romantic my favorite letter to
demonstrate this is from 1942 late in
the year when the Allies have begun to
win in North Africa and the prime
minister of New Zealand Peter Fraser
writes a letter to Winston Churchill and
says things are better there now you've
got one of our few divisions and the
best of them and we need them back home
in Churchill right simulator now first
of all something north of 40 percent of
the total British war effort is supplied
by nations from the Empire
Franklin Roosevelt could never get this
fact through his skull right it's a real
practical thing in a massive war and
numbers count where are you going to get
the force to stop that craziness over
there right and so cheers alright rides
him back and he says you know Prime
Minister I still think that the most
important stuff is over here and I urge
you to let them stay and so then a week
passes and he writes again Frazer and he
says we've talked about it in the
cabinet and we've debated it in our
House of Commons and we agree they can
stay you see what that means that means
all he really had to do was send a cable
to the general come home and the general
would have got himself home
now Churchill's looking for that he's
looking for millions of free people
hundreds of millions to raise a force to
stop this possibility of global
despotism as wicked as the Hitler global
despotism and so he thinks about the UN
but then soon enough he starts
qualifying that because the next thing
he says is and this is the first time
where he introduces into this speech the
differences between kinds of nations the
beginning of the speech is all of the
nations and he says it would be criminal
madness to give the secret of the
nuclear weapon to the world in the
condition that's in so the UN gets some
weapons but not the big weapon and not
the one that decides everything for the
time being nobody would sleep in he has
slept any less restfully whatever he
says because it's the United States and
Great Britain and Canada that have this
secret and it would be different if
those other guys had it so first of all
the call is qualified by the claims of
friendship and then he goes on to
explain what he means by that he talks
about the Soviet Union he never
threatens any aggression against them oh
he qualifies the thing about the health
and safety the comfort and welfare with
this phrase it is not our duty to
interfere in the affairs of nations that
we have not conquered in war which is of
course most of the world he says how are
we going to get there
welfare he quotes an American in one of
his mentor's I was a let's say a
particular friend of Churchill's mother
that was delicate I don't know what
Andrew thinks about that but I I think
they were particularly and and and he
was a great man he would fill Madison
Square Garden this man Bourke Cockran
and so he hadn't seen Bourke Cockran for
forty-five years but he says in this
Beach I remember an American friend
Bourke Cockran and he said the earth is
a generous mother if the people will but
cultivate her soil in justice and in
peace there is enough for all free
market property rights not communism see
and then he says the crux of what he's
traveled here to say and and I have
almost no disagreements in life with
Andrew Robertson where I disagree I'm
wrong but he actually says in his book
that this is not the crux and I think it
is there you go ha take that you know
you need a microphone yeah so it so he
yeah and and what is the crux a special
relationship with Britain and America
why first because they can talk and
that's the way free people there's only
two ways for human beings to get along
and one is talking in the others force
and we can talk and then he says what do
we say we must never cease to proclaim
in fearless tones and then he quotes
Cassie where Andrew and I were laughing
about this last night it takes a genius
right but Winston Churchill actually
turns over forty years consistently the
American Declaration of Independence
into a pact of friendship between
Britain and the United States you know I
I remember the first time I had dinner
with my wife's parents before before we
were married and and she said something
about America and about its beginnings
and how it was British yeah and I said
yeah we had the divorce independence
which declared our independence
from the British tyrant wasn't a
diplomatic hit but I asked my
father-in-law if he could if I could
marry his daughter first he tortured me
he made me wait for like 45 minutes
while he watched TV
Arthur Negus antique road show
we had a plot they had tea at the same
time every day they're British and you
could just set the clock by them having
tea and so we were gonna arrive on a
Sunday and we were gonna arrive for tea
and then when Jocelyn Penny's mother
rolled the trolley away I would stay
behind the nastiness if I could marry
Finney and so off goes the trolley
Denis and I said Denis and he said
Arthur Negus and he gets up and turns on
the TV I'm watching this guy who's got
these boots that are made out of coal
polished up and they're speculating how
much these boots are worth they're
they're actually lumps of coal
why am I doing this and then he turned
it off and he said he said I said Denis
he said have I shown you my collection
of glass so so I had I gotta go look at
it again right and then we sit down I
said Denis and you're the big eyebrows
who came up and I said I've asked penny
to marry me and she's done the honor
saying yes if you approve and he held
out his hand see this you'll like this
he said Jocelyn and I have always said
that we wish all Americans could be like
you yeah he insulted my country
[Laughter]
special relationship anyway that's all
that's very important things to me in my
life of course and he was a very you
know my wife father-in-law was a camp
commander of a Japanese powa aunt for
four years and that's you know not easy
duty three and a half years so Churchill
thinks that the energy that comes from
the principles of freedom can unite the
world and the people who can lead that
are the people in whose language the
principles were best articulated and
that's not parochialism that's a
recognition of the force and meaning of
human speech and Churchill rang all the
changes on that for his whole life
now let's go back conditions change and
so policies change how do you think
about NATO today well wouldn't you think
about it and you know I myself favor its
continuation but I also think that it's
there to do a job and to do that job
reliably under pressure as the kind that
comes in war it needs to be a bunch of
an alliance among a bunch of people who
have reached a fundamental agreement
about all the purposes of life I think
that's what Winston Churchill thought
was strong and I think you know with the
shifts in the world and the stuff that's
going on but then finally my last point
is a change of principle that is
threatened and that's what has to be
resisted in my opinion because what is
the change first of all there's been
this revolution in government all across
the West and in China by the way which
proceeds according to not unrelated
principles to what dominate in many
Western countries
and that is that because we now know and
you'll see that this is sort of akin to
the principles of the Old South now that
we know that everything is an evolution
everything has changed so not nature not
the laws of nature and nature's God
change change and hope I guess you'd say
we ourselves our own being is altering
all the time
and what makes this remarkable now is
that we know that you know Hegel's great
inside the owl of Minerva flies at dusk
we've always been victims of the process
of history but at the end of history we
can see the process and then we can take
control and the way we take control is
that we bring the tools of modern
science to bear on the governing of
human beings and we rationalize and make
scientific to society once the Churchill
saw this coming first time I know of him
talking of it is in 1898 but
consistently through his life after that
and that means that this thing and see
once you once you adopt that principle
that the the rightful rule below to the
one who can make a scientific plan for
the society can you see how there's an
automatic tendency to centralization
because make a plan for everybody that's
one reason why in education today we
forget we it's actually invisible to us
that the learning is in the student and
that each one has to have the experience
and they and their contribution to it
will be decisive and that means
education is not something we are doing
to them we do that with them but mostly
they do it once you understand that by
the way you just watch them blossom just
tell them it's their problem
I'll help and they okay I've got
something to do you're not anymore
saying you have to do what I say you're
saying do you want to know this
this beautiful and precious thing do you
want to know this because that would be
hard not sure you're up to it
but if you are I love you you see that's
the whole disposition of government that
flows from the Declaration of
Independence or what Churchill called
the title deeds and the Magna Carta and
the petition of right the flow from
those right and this new idea is that
it's got to be trained by experts but of
course once you get that principle why
do you need the nation-state that's why
this movement toward internationalism
Andrew in one of very many fine things
but one of the very best things in his
book as he produces a quote that I did
not know and it's Churchill says and
I'll only paraphrase it but hogwash this
is these laws and these things that
these are the job of governments with
the European Union the movement for
which he helped to create we're not
talking about that we're talking about
something else we're talking about
alliances for trade and protection but
see if it's a fact that we are being
encouraged to surrender our authority
over our government then that's a change
in regime and to the extent that these
alliances that we have have morphed into
that kind of thing
my own view is that we should not
abandon them my view is that we should
reform them so they are back to what
they were in the mind of Winston
Churchill thank you
anybody want to say anything no if
there's not one question you don't get
your dessert Andrew do you want to say
anything take him a microphone wait
you're not saying he was better than I
was
[Laughter]
thank you very much I've got two things
to say the first is that that was a very
profound lecture you just gave Larry we
are so lucky to have you
and the second thing is I wonder if you
could just say a little bit more about I
think the thing that we disagreed with
on the sinews of speech of peace speech
is the idea of from Stetten in the bolt
in the voltage i'd like yeah so I say
I'd like you to talk a little bit more
about his stance on on communism and the
fundamental evil of communism that he
that he mentions in that speech because
my sense was that he'd already in the
Harvard speech in 1943 said the
important things about about the
anglo-american Lance and a special
relationship so I'd like you to say a
little bit more about the moral the
moral fury that he felt about about what
communism did to the human condition
very good see remember when I disagreed
with Andrea that I said that on
occasions when I do he's right and so
there's a reason why the speech is
remembered is the iron curtain speech
which is not what Churchill called it
because the dramatic thing he said and
it's it's like the utmost particular
from Stetten in the Baltic to Trieste in
the Adriatic an Iron Curtain has fallen
across Europe
and then he describes it's very lovely
because you know Churchill had a gift
you know he had so many but there
there's two kinds of paragraphs that he
could write and he wrote them many
different times and better than anybody
I know ever did he can describe freedom
in a little speech called civilization
what does it mean it means the rule of
civilians
it means independent courts it means
freedom of speech he just gives us lists
right there's a there's one of those
lists is in the iron curtain speech and
the other thing is he can describe
tyranny and its ugliness and its terror
right and I says that the Nazis ones
that you know in the blood toil tears
and sweat speech he says something in
the the worst in the dark lamentable
catalogue of human crime he's got it so
in other words the thing that the speech
did was name the enemy and nobody had
done that not Churchill he'd not done
that he had there's a great letter in
the Churchill archive there are few
there's a there's one by the way the
exactly parallel letter in the London
Times letter to the editor of the London
Times the owner and it's a long letter
about how they've been wrong about
everything for 20 years not sent and
then a shorter letter not sent and then
a letter that's about that long so he
writes this letter to Stalin 1944 and he
just hammers him and what the Soviets
have done knots in and then he shorter
one not sent and then the last one all
of that is reduced to one sentence I am
afraid I was never any good at Carl Marx
so he got it off his chest right but he
couldn't say it now he gets to say it
and that provides the practical
organizing purpose of world foreign
policy American front foot andrew is
exactly right about that but and and and
my point is only that negative things
have no independent existence of their
own they are only the spoiling of
positive things and so Churchill did
wish to emphasize the positive things
right because that is what we fight for
and also how we will go about fighting
see and I and and the speeches you know
because by the way the speech ends with
the most amazing flattery of the United
States a few days before he had said
that not since Rome has any people
enjoyed such a primacy of power right
but it ends with praise of the British
Empire and you know the first thing and
the last thing is the most prominent
thing in any book so our speech so what
I think is I think that he thought that
you know and see this a shut up now but
I'll close with this point and I'm
confident andrew agrees with it is that
the modern world is very different from
the ancient world in so many ways and
one of them is its global and that means
that when evil arises in it and it does
as it did in the ancient world when it
arises in it it could conquer everything
Churchill is aware of this right his
fears of war are expressed in eloquent
speeches and essays where you know shall
we all commit suicide right and it means
that you you actually now need an
organizing principle for the world in
order to resist those horrors and where
did you find it
right he finds it in the American
Declaration of Independence and it's
four bears in the British heritage and
they are great not because they're
British or American they are great
because they are human and we are a
noble because we adopted them thanks
[Applause]